this internal memo from sunrise hospital
points to covet positive volumes surging
over the past several days with over 160
positive patients
on sunday in this letter to medical
staff dated
august 4th ceo todd glamberg writes
that recent measures taken will continue
to sunday
august 9th including a temporary halt on
transfers from other hospitals
and adult elective surgery and
procedures requiring
any inpatient stay he writes i want to
assure you
we will do everything we can to support
the care of your patients
and then in bold please do not let a
patient's condition deteriorate
if your patient needs sunrise hospital
please contact us and we will review
on a case-by-case basis since the start
of the coronavirus pandemic
the i-team has been reaching out to
hospitals in southern nevada
most do not reveal numbers the nevada
hospital association provides a broader
picture
as of august 3 for clark county it
reports 83 percent of licensed beds
occupied
85 percent of adult icu beds occupied
and 55 percent of ventilators in use
in his memo sclamberg writes hardships
have been extended over
longer stretches of time no one could
have ever foreseen